maintenant les ukrainiens continuent de
fuir les régions visées est frappé par
par les russes je rappelle qu en un peu
plus de quatre semaines cette guerre a
jeté sur les routes des millions
d'ukrainiens 3 8 millions d'entre eux
ont déjà fui le pays selon un dernier
décompte de l'onu communiquées hier plus
de la moitié d'entre eux sont accueillis
en pologne une vague migratoire que vous
avez découvert pour nous sur le terrain
de chasse bonjour vous êtes d'ordinaire
notre notre correspondante à berlin que
vous allez gagner dans l'est dans les
prochaines heures de nouveau vous avez
couvert dès le 27 février donc trois
jours après le début de l'invasion russe
ses premières arrivées à la frontière
vous êtes resté plusieurs semaines
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus frappé
qu'est ce que vous allez retenir
aujourd'hui écoutez je pense que ce qui
m'a frappé plus c'était la détresse des
gens des gens qui arrivent des gens qui
arrivent sans rien avec souvent juste un
sac à dos avec quelques effets
personnels qu'ils ont plus à mener
lorsque je suis arrivé donc trois jours
après le début de l'invasion russe
envoyait ces gens avec les traits tirés
avec tous vraiment ce désespoir qui se
notait sur sur leurs visages qui venait
d'arriver en pologne et qui finalement
était complètement perdu encore sous le
choc et ça ça a continué il ya des
centaines de milliers d'ukrainiens et de
personnes qui étaient bloquées en
ukraine qui ont pris ce chemin de l'exil
et surtout ce qu'il faut se rappeler
c'est qu'il s'agit principalement de
femmes d'enfants et de personnes âgées
les femmes et les enfants c'est 90% de
cette de cette population migratoire
donc c'est vraiment très particulier
très spécifique à 7 à cette frontière là
et puis évidemment ce qui est très
marquant vous voyez cette cette femme
qui a quitté l'ukraine et venait de
traverser la frontière ils étaient vingt
mètres sur le territoire polonais elle
regardait en arrière ce qui est très
frappant c'est qu'ils ont tout à fait
conscience d'avoir dû quitter leur pays
qu'ils regardent peut-être leur pays
pour la dernière fois donc ça c'est
extrêmement c'était extrêmement
touchants voilà des témoignages
vous en avez pour pour nous aujourd'hui
injustement cette femme oui j'ai
rencontré évidemment j'ai rencontré
plusieurs l'ukrainien certains m'ont
parlé de leur route vers l'exil j'ai
rencontré in à une femme de louhansk qui
avait déjà dû fuir une première fois sa
ville natale et s'est installé en 2014
en ukraine centrale en espérant pouvoir
il refaire sa vie ça faisait huit ans
qu'elle vivait dans une auberge de
jeunesse après avoir tout perdu elle a
repris la route de l'exil je vous
propose de l'écouter
maintenant que nous sommes ici je suis
contente de rencontrer ces gens
proposent d'aller en espagne je veux y
aller il n'y a rien qui manquait à
louer nous avons tout perdu j'avais un
magasin vous avez une grande maison
était donc j'étais une femme d'affaires
maintenant je n'ai plus rien je veux
aller quelque part je veux juste
retourner travailler ça ne me fait pas
peur
voilà les adieux au mans au revoir aux
hommes à leur pays alors bien alors à
leur statut aussi vous avez largement
documenté pour nous ces dernières
semaines emmanuel un accueil
impressionnant qui s'est structuré en
pologne au fil des semaines mais qui
fait aussi face à un certain nombre de
difficultés oui tout à fait déjà à
l'arrivée sans précédent de ces
centaines de milliers de personnes c'est
très difficilement gérable pour les
autorités polonaises elles sont en cela
aidé par des ong venues du monde entier
j'ai rencontré par exemple des pompiers
français qui venait prêter main-forte il
ya aussi énormément de bénévoles qui
viennent de leur propre chef initiative
spontanée initiative spontanée alors ça
ça aussi un revers à cette médaille
finalement c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
sont très bien intentionnés et aussi sur
ses frontières on va rencontrer des gens
beaucoup moins bien intentionnés il va
falloir notamment faire attention au
trafic d'êtres humains qui a lieu en
fait ça dépend des des postes frontières
y en a qui sont très bien organisée très
bien encadrés par les services de
sécurité par les policiers les pompiers
polonais par exemple d'autres sont
beaucoup moins fréquentée et c'est là
que les populations vulnérables qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure donc les femmes
les enfants les personnes âgées
sont plus à même de faire des mauvaises
rencontres êtes vous en avez été témoin
personnellement oui tout à fait j'ai vu
j'ai pu voir des trafiquants qui
attendait justement de pouvoir de
pouvoir mettre la main sur des gens en
détresse et tout le monde arrive en
détresse est évidemment la majeure
partie des gens vont pouvoir faire
attention vont pouvoir se dire non je
pas suivre cette personne que je ne
connais pas mais il ya aussi énormément
de gens qui en a qui sont tellement en
situation de traumatismes qu'ils ne vont
pas forcément faire attention à qui ils
vont suivre et c'est là évidemment que
les choses peuvent tourner très mal
points merci beaucoup à emmanuel d'être
passés par notre plateau parisien